boom on May 12 25 88 the town of
kangastak Greenland was destroyed by a
devastating four kiloton explosion
accompanied by a massive electromagnetic
pulse the few survivors that made it
through the incident alive described
seeing a pale green light in the area at
the time of the explosion shortly after
an omk a class scenario or end of death
scenario began in which all
multicellular life on Earth began to
experience a regenerative effect
regardless of injury or illness in other
words nobody could die anymore this
resulted in intense worldwide panic in
the face of the inexplicable occurrence
as the Panic mounted the o5 Council of
the FCP Foundation held an emergency
meeting in order to address the
possibilities at hand meanwhile
civilians began reporting sightings of a
gigantic pale white humanoid monster
rampaging through their cities and
communities wrecking havoc and violently
attacking anyone and anything in its
path as the situation progressed and
worsened and the reality of the end of
death scenario began to set in the SCP
Foundation made the difficult decision
to lift its veil of secrecy and reveal
itself to the world 05-1 made a
statement to the UN regarding the
reality of the worldwide anomaly
advising citizens to remain calm and
await further instructions five days
after the world learned the truth of the
SCP Foundation the pale monster arrived
in St John's Newfoundland where it was
met by mobile Task Force new 7 hammer
down for what they hoped would be a
quick fight and neutralization instead
two years of devastating bloody combat
ensued by July 4th 2590 ninety percent
of the Task Force personnel had been
killed and regenerated an average of
five times at this point MTF News 7
abandoned the city of Saint John citing
anomalously poor working conditions
after being held in place for two years
the monster was able to break through
the defensive line and continue its
Rampage on October 10th 2590 the SCP
Foundation and the global occult
Coalition came together in an act of
unprecedented cooperation to found
project Beluga dedicated to the goal of
neutralizing the monster designated SCP
ubu and stopping its reign of terror but
project Beluga was unable to neutralize
the entity before it reached Columbus
Ohio on December 29 2590 once it arrived
in the city SCP ubu began dedicating its
time to a gruesome personal project
first it dug a two kilometer deep hole
in the city center next it gathered a
total of 2.9 Million civilians throwing
them into the hole after the hole was
full The Entity leaped into the upper
Stratosphere over and over again
stomping into the hole each time when
the people inside were pulverized The
Entity destroyed a large fountain which
it used as a cup and drank the resulting
juices from the hole this entire process
took roughly one year and when it was
finished the entity appeared to grow
bored with Columbus and moved to Lake
Erie upon reaching Lake Erie SCP ubu
trudged out into the water and began
assaulting the cargo ship stock there it
began lifting ships up and throwing them
out of the water some flying high enough
to exit Earth's gravitational pole
altogether two of the ships were later
spotted on the surface of the Moon this
chaos and destruction continued for
years and years until June 10 2670 when
SCP ubu was contained at SCP Foundation
site 59 however this containment only
lasted for two minutes at which point
The Entity escaped and made its way to
New York City where it was found howling
and attempted to defile the Statue of
Liberty several countries used their
nuclear arsenals to attack scp-u-bu over
the course of its Rampage until the
Schenectady agreement was signed on
February 10 2674 cementing an agreement
between NATO Powers the Russian
Federation the People's Republic of
China and the global occult Coalition
all signatories agree that due to the
concerns around the environment any
additional nuclear strikes against the
entity would be prohibited after the
signing was finished
scp-ubu crashed the ceremony grabbing
several lengths of rebar and 15 foreign
dignitaries which it used to construct
itself a b necklace the next notable
incident occurred when SCP ubu showed up
at site 19 interrupting a round of
testing with SCP AFF a woman capable of
turning matter into stone by speaking to
it SCP ubu broke through the ceiling
crushing AFF beneath its weight
scp-682 which was also present
approached the entity curiously and SCP
ubu responded by angrily defecating and
shouting at scp-682 in gibberish
scp-682 seemed to understand stand this
vocalization and attacked scp-ubu
demanding that it take back the insult
at this point SCP UVU slapped 682's
cheek causing 682 to let out a horrific
screen the slap left behind a glowing
green Mark which spread over the entity
of 682's body before breaking the bonds
of its cells all at once dissolving the
reptile into a pool of toxic fluid
scp-ubu then spent five minutes bathing
in this fluid while giggling after
finishing its bath devouring the
reconstituted scp-aff and screaming into
the microphone for 20 minutes SCP ubu
broke into armed containment area 179
and swallowed
scp-2317 hole on March 5th 2686
scp-ubu conducted an assault on formula
class scp-2000 rendering it neutralized
again years of Hell passed as project
Beluga struggled to come up with new
methods that had not already been
exhausted meanwhile civilians did their
best to find ways to cope with the state
of the world on March 25th 2750 former
film star Nash Degroot published the
Zonk Manifesto A book based around a
simple principle life on Earth was no
longer worth living consciously and the
only way formed was to enter an eternal
coma through the combination of
chemicals and guided meditation this
kick-started the social movement the
international Zonk on June 24 2790
project Beluga forces managed to drive
SCP ubu into the Bay of Bengal where it
remained for three years causing very
little trouble aside from underwater
seismic events meanwhile the
international zong continued to grow and
one massive adherence known as cuddle
Topia reached its goal of 5 million
residents on June 10 2793 SCP ubu flung
scp-3000 out of the ocean leaving it
beached on the soil of India several
cities were destroyed in this process
The Entity then spent a week pointing
and laughing at The Beached sea monster
before grabbing it by the tip of its
tail and beginning to drag it across
Asia SCP ubu continued carving a path
through Asia the wriggling scp-3000 in
tow until it reached the Bering Strait
then it began to cross the strait into
Alaska returning to North American
territory once more but it didn't stop
there instead advancing towards South
America until it and scp-3000 arrived on
the eastern coast of Brazil on August 29
2793 there it dragged its unfortunate
charge back into the ocean once more
disappearing from sight on August 30th
scp-169 or the Leviathan emerged from
the depths of the ocean there are some
reports that scp-3000 had been tied
around its neck but these have not been
confirmed the Leviathan and SCP ubu then
entered into a lengthy battle which
carried on for several hundred years
after so much time had passed that
Witnesses could scarcely remember a time
when it wasn't happening the fight
between scp-ubu and scp-169 came to a
halt much as it had with scp-682
scp-ubu slapped scp-169 across the face
with such force that its cell bonds
dissolved and it melted into a puddle of
fluid which was lost beneath the ocean
waves
scp-169 was reclassified neutralized
December 11 3020 marked the start of a
10-year period of inactivity for SCP ubu
ordinarily one would expect this to come
with a sense of relief however even in
spite of the global immortality the
collateral damage from scp-ubu's
centuries of Carnage had rendered the
surface of the Earth uninhabitable with
all land now underwater the remains of
human civilization persist on a single
archipelago of floating cities
constructed from ships and debris
meanwhile the international Zonk
movement has persist tested gaining more
and more traction and popularity as
conscious life became less and less
bearable an enormous floating Zonk pile
consisting of international Zonk
followers using anomalous methods to
achieve the perfect Zonk began to form
eventually this pile earned the nickname
new zonkland by May 28 3028 the
archipelago was abandoned and the 140
remaining conscious humans retreated to
the SCP foundation's scps Naismith there
they lived in relative safety for
several months until SCP ubu was spotted
in the water off the port bow of the
naysmith on January 14 3030. it emitted
several sounds that Witnesses described
as mocking before swimming off towards
new zonklin in response to this
reappearance after 10 years of
inactivity the o5 council called an
emergency meeting the transcript for
this meeting reads as follows we haven't
exhausted all of our anomalous options
for neutralizing ubu where's the Corn
Creek we've been over since Lawrence
answering the corn cake in this mess is
only going to it just anchored 57 clicks
to Southeast for why the hell did you
tell him that well friends it seems the
Omega K has had us up in about so long
that our personalities have run out of
fuel we were given from birth in all
likelihood we'd see better
professionalism and teamwork in new
zonkland as a matter of fact that's a
good segue into what I was about to
propose and frankly I hope you find the
nicest cleanest spots in the mass grave
where are you going that depends which
way is southeast at this point o5-11
left the room presumably to track down
the Corn Creek leaving the remains of
the o5 council there and leaving the
remains of project Beluga with the
question of how to handle SCP ubu
according to its official SCP Foundation
file SCP ubu is an extremely violent and
hostile humanoid entity of Unknown
Origin which appeared in Greenland on
May 12 2588 it displays anomalous
physical strength and speed as well as
reality bending capabilities and the
emission of regenerative Lambda waves
linked to the ongoing end of death
scenario the appearance of SCP ubu and
the start of the end of death scenario
coincided with several additional
phenomenon there was a mass loss of
function for all the objects operated by
the three moons initiative the three
moons initiative was an extra
dimensional human organization based in
scp-2922-c or the afterlife known as
corbenic this organization was founded
14 000 years ago with the purpose of
establishing a human colony in the
afterlife it has long maintained a peace
treaty with the SCP Foundation
scp-2922 a method of communication that
allowed a human mind to make calls to
any pre-established phone number ceased
all functions next the extra dimensional
space known as The Wanderers Library a
magical Archive of all the knowledge
from all known worlds and every book
that has ever been written will be
written and and several that have not
and will not exist was severed from
Earth when the SCP Foundation pressed
the Serpent's hand for answers a
representative answered that
irreconcilable security concerns
regarding Earth had come up and forced
them to make this decision a
representative of Marshall Carter and
dark limited somehow gained access to
the personal contact information of the
o5 council's members and use this
information to reach out to them with a
business offer the company is ordinarily
on unfriendly terms with the SCP
Foundation due to their conflicting
interests namely Marshall Carter and
dark's interests in acquiring and
selling anomalous items entities and
experiences to the highest bidder
however in this case the company's
representative approached 05 council
members with a mixture of politeness and
Desperation begging the SCP Foundation
to purchase large amounts of the
company's stock the force known as
scp-4000 lost all of its anomalous
properties all at once investigation
revealed only a small parchment note in
the area's entryway which read good luck
one of the most perplexing and
disconcerting phenomenon that occurred
concurrently with SCP ubu's first
appearance was what happened to scp-3008
the infinite Ikea though this sort of
thing should have been impossible the
infinite Ikea was anomalously purchased
by some unknown entity the Ikea branding
was stricken from the building and it
was converted into an emergency shelter
all of these occurrences combine to
serve as a warning something big is
coming and indeed it was
scp-u-b-u it appears to be impervious to
most forms of damage including blunt
force trauma heavy caliber machine gun
fire temperatures up to 1600 degrees
Kelvin artillery fire and Direct Energy
discharge from other anomalies it did
express some discomfort when exposed to
severe simultaneous direct nuclear
strikes but it was not affected beyond
that they only recorded instance of
lasting damage to SC pubu was on August
14 2784 in which the entity bit its left
thumb seemingly for no reason other than
curiosity after biting its thumb The
Entity screamed for seven days straight
then entered into a month-long crying
fit 30 years and 14 days later the thumb
had completely healed SCP ubu stands at
a height of 4.3 meters one exact measure
of its weight is unknown attempts at
measurement during its brief time and
containment showed that its weight is at
least 15 399 kilograms its exact
anatomical composition is unknown but a
superficial examination of the entity
indicates that its body shape resembles
that of a large androgynous humanoid
covered in hairless white skin similar
in texture to that of a dolphin or small
whale The Entity has no eyes ears or
nostrils but seems to still possess the
ability to see hear and smell its only
visible sensory organ aside from its
skin is its 0.5 meter wide mouth
humanoid in nature with a prehensile
tongue of unknown lengths on its lower
body it has no apparent features aside
from a colaweka that it uses to dispose
of waste SCP ubu is prone to
vocalizations mainly screaming laughing
and babbling but it does not appear to
understand speech in any known language
nor does it seem to be attempting to
communicate with anyone it encounters
its primary interest appears to be
destruction and causing as much of it as
possible it will attack anything that it
can get its hands on but seems to show a
particular preference for attacking and
consuming human beings in large populous
areas such as cities its demeanor is
both sadistic and childlike and it has
been seen playing with its victims for
hours before moving on to a new Target
due to its regenerative effect present
in SCP ubu's vicinity it is incapable of
causing permanent damage to any living
thing and seems to have no greater
motivation Beyond causing fear and pain
SCP ubu is classified as Tiamat meaning
that it cannot be reasonably contained
at this time with the resources that the
foundation has therefore the focus has
shifted from containment to
neutralization which is ongoing via
project Beluga any and all non-critical
resources will be funneled into project
Beluga as neutralization of SCP ubu is a
top priority additional information on
neutralization efforts is restricted and
may only be accessed by members of
project Beluga but in the end it won't
be project Beluga that defeats this
monstrous creature it'll be the staunch
efforts of one extremely dedicated
researcher now check out the o5 council
must die as cp001 the way it ends or
borocycle and insane scp-001 fight gate
Guardian vs Scarlet King